أشعر وكأنني سأتناول
وجبة خاصة هنا،
طعام رواد الفضاء، إنه المستقبل، هذا هو
طعام الفضاء،
أعتقد أن رواد الفضاء يتمتعون بصحة جيدة في
المهمات الطويلة في الفضاء، مما يمثل العديد من
التحديات، والطعام يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا.
فينوم باجلي هي المؤسس المشارك للكتاب
الواقعي  أطلقت شركة التصميم التي كانت واحدة من
العديد من المتأهلين للتصفيات النهائية في مسابقة ناسا ووكالة
الفضاء الكندية
تحدي الغذاء في الفضاء السحيق،
لذا فإن الذهاب إلى المريخ سيستغرق
عامين ونصف ذهابًا وإيابًا ولا
يمكن لرواد الفضاء تناول سوى الكثير من الأطعمة
المجففة بالتجميد.  الأطعمة قبل أن تصبح
مجنونة، فما هي بعض هذه
الخضر التي نراها هنا، نعم،
هذه حديقة للزراعة الهوائية، لذا يمكنك
رؤية بعض أنواع البوك تشوي الصغيرة، ويمكنك رؤية بعضها
مثل خضار الزبدة، وهو أمر غير خيالي يطلق على
هذا مختبر طهي، إنه
نموذج عمل لوحدة معيارية يمكن وضعها
في مركبة فضائية، فهي تزرع الطعام
وتحتوي على آلة صنع القهوة ويمكنها حتى شواء اللحوم كما
نعلم جميعًا أن النيران المفتوحة تثير الاستياء في
الفضاء، نعم، دعونا نتجنب ذلك بشكل صحيح،
لذا ما قررنا فعله هو  استخدم
الميكروويف بشكل أساسي لتسخين اللحم
ثم رسم
نمط الشواية على البروتين باستخدام الليزر مما يجعل
قطعة الدجاج هذه تبدو أكثر
شهية. المساحة المناسبة للشواء عذر
الشواء. هذا الجزء من معمل الطهي
هو ما يسميه الكتاب الواقعي مونش.
مفاعل حيوي ينمي الطحالب التي يمكن أن يحصدها
رواد الفضاء ويأكلونها، لذا فإن
ما نفعله هو أننا نستخرج هذه
الأقراص الصغيرة من الطحالب الدقيقة ثم
نحصل في النهاية على الكثير منها، ثم تنبعث
منها رائحة كريهة وليس
مذاقها رائعًا ولكنها  مغذية جدًا، لذا
ما نفعله هو أنه لإخفاء النكهة، نقوم
بخلطها مع الكثير من
الأنواع المختلفة من المكونات، وها أنت في
كيس من السيليكون ثم تقوم بخلطها
ثم ينتهي بها الأمر على شكل كرات مثل هذه، لذا هناك
شيء واحد يجب فعله  إن معرفة الطعام في الفضاء
يشبه أن براعم التذوق لديك لا تعمل
بنفس الطريقة التي تعمل بها عندما تكون على
السطح،
فالطعام الذي نقدمه لرواد الفضاء هو
في الواقع لاذع للغاية بالنسبة لهم حتى
يشعرون بأي شيء صحيح، نعم،
نكهات قوية جدًا، إنها جيدة جدًا  لن يكون الأمر
خفيًا، لا
يزال سيئًا، حسنًا،
إنه لذيذ، حسنًا بالتأكيد، يمكنني
تناول هذا طوال الوقت، إنه جيد حقًا،
يمكن أن يكون لطعم التحضير ومظهر الطعام فوائد نفسية حقيقية
لرواد الفضاء، ومثل الكثير من
الناس، سيحتاجون إلى
قهوة الصباح الخاصة بهم  علاوة على كونها مجرد
قهوة، يمكننا أن نجعلها
مغذية للغاية، لذا ما يمكننا فعله هنا
هو إضافة مسحوق القهوة، سأضيف
نوعين مختلفين من الدهون هنا، لدي
زيت MCT المصنوع من جوز الهند ثم
لدي السمن الذي هو في الأساس
شكل ثابت من الزبدة، نعم عفوًا،
وسأضيف الليسيثين الذي
يشبه المستحلب
[موسيقى]
للتجربة [موسيقى] يا إلهي،
الثلج رائحته جيدة جدًا، إنه
لذيذ جدًا، قهوة فضائية
ولم أستطع تخيله  سيكون ذلك
دسمًا ورغويًا ولذيذًا،
أحب قهوة الفضاء، حسنًا، شكرًا لك